(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah, hi, Drew, it's so lovely to see you!
Oh, my gosh.
Seth, I feel like I've known you for such a long time.
It's been, we're probably closing in on two decades.
I wouldn't be surprised if it's been 20 years
since we first met.
I think it has been around something like that.
You got 20 Emmy Award nominations for SNL, is that correct?
Thank you for focusing on that and not the one win.
(audience and Drew laughing)
By the way, the Emmy's like are so hard,
I would be with like Amy Poehler and Kristen Wiig and me
and none of us would ever win
and we'd go back to my house and have a big party.
You know what, a true story, I think the most,
and by the way, it's an honor to be nominated,
let me stress that, the most upset I ever was
when SNL didn't win an Emmy, I was also at your house.
And let me tell you,
that was a wonderful constellation prize
to get to party at Drew Barrymore's house after a big loss.
That was one of my favorite nights of life,
and Amy Poehler got me this like beautiful decanter
because she kept talking about how
this was such a great antidote.
And then she got me a bottle that said, antidote, on it
and it still sits on my desk.
I just love it so much.
I'm gonna tell you from knowing Amy for years,
if she ever gives you a gift
that's her way of saying, I stole something that night.
(audience laughs)
Good!
Well, I didn't notice anything was missing.
And that decanter with that like engraved antidote
is like my personal treasure.
If anyone ever stole that, I'd come after them.
(audience laughs)
Just don't have her back over.
No, I want all of you guys.
I mean, you're a part of the legacy and institution.
You know, I did SNL for the first time in '82,
I think it was such a training ground for me.
And you, you know, for two decades, I worked with you
as the head writer
and we did a lot of sketches together also, which was fun.
I remember us playing Posh and Becks in a Donatella sketch.
We both look great,
look how young and great we look.
I know, I haven't worn like a dress like that
probably since that night.
My wife makes me wear that white suit every night.
I'm so happy for you
because when we knew each other back in the day,
two decades ago, you know, we were both young
and like single and free and like carefree
and, you know, I have two kids, you have a beautiful family
with your gorgeous wife and your two sons
and I was curious because, you know,
we launched the show and I had, you know, my two children,
I was trying to homeschool and launch the show
and it was such a ridiculous juggling act.
And I would see you come out in, is it your in-laws attic?
Yeah, I was in my attic and then my in-laws house
we moved over the course of the summer.
What was it like to do that show with your two kids?
Well first of all, I want to give you a round of applause
for launching a show during a pandemic.
It was hard enough to do a show
but at least we had some understanding
about what our show was and how to go about it.
So I'm just amazed
that you and your entire crew over there pulled it off,
that is just such an accomplishment.
It was a trip, you know, I think my kids in their head
thinks it's pretty cool that their dad has a TV show.
But then when I started saying, I'm gonna go up to the attic
to do my TV show I think they thought I was making it up
but they were great.
I mean, they had a real understanding of it.
And the one upside was, you know,
to this awful year is I did see my kids more
than if I was doing it from the studio.
So they appreciated it
and all in all they were pretty good kids about it.
Well, thank goodness for that.
And I just want to ask you a question
as I hold up the Drew's News mug,
why do we crave satirical news, good news, funny news?
What is so powerful about the news in the context of
this sort of information yet pithy delivery?
The only thing I would say about the way we approach it is
that news more often than not, unfortunately is not good
and we try to run through the news of the day
with as many jokes as possible
so that the watching of it might provide a little catharsis.
It certainly is cathartic for us to write about it that way.
And the fact that there might be an audience
that wants to consume what we're putting together
is incredibly flattering to us.
(bright music)